federal regulators are urging big banks
to help government employees affected by
the partial shutdown Wells Fargo one of
the nation's largest banks is among
those taking action the company
announced its waiving fees for federal
employees it will also help identify
financial assistance options for those
unable to pay their bills during this
time Wells Fargo CEO Tim Sloan is here
with an interview you'll see first on
CBS this morning
good morning to you Tim Sloan morning
Yael well it's been a rough couple of
years for Wells Fargo you'll be glad to
know we're gonna give you a chance to
address that a little bit later on but
we want to start with the government
shutdown 35 days and Counting we were
asking about the federal employees who
are customers of your bank do you have
numbers on that and what you're doing to
help them sure we do we have about
750,000 customers that receive a direct
deposit from the federal government so
we're assuming that all those customers
are impacted by the in our furloughed
and so when they stopped receiving their
first check a few weeks ago we began to
waive all their overdraft fees waive any
sort of late fees that's total of now
about 3 million dollars and then we're
reaching out to those customers and
saying to them gosh if you need any sort
of help in terms of loan payments let us
know we'll defer loan payments we've now
were now in the process of discussing
that with about 14400 of our customers
Gail it's very similar to what we've
done in the past for not a man-made
disaster but a weather-related in terms
of hurricanes and and the wildfires in
California the Commerce Secretary say
listen people just go get a bank loan
what were you what what were your
thoughts about that when you heard it
and are you offering as some companies
are zero same day zero interest loans
for federal employees i I didn't think
those comments were particularly
appropriate given the situation these
are these are federal employees that
want to work and some of them are
working and they're protecting us
they're risking their lives every day
and the thought that we're not paying
them I think of the country it's
completely embarrassing the way that
we're helping our customers in addition
to waiving fees it's deferring payment
so what we what we'll do is we'll defer
their paint and loan payments for all
types of loans and then the other thing
that we're doing is we're suppressing
any sort of reporting to credit agencies
so they shouldn't be impacted this this
situation shouldn't impact their credit
but some credit unions are giving people
low loans with no interest no cost loans
is that just something Wells Fargo is
too big can't do for federal work no
absolutely not it's just it's something
we've the first and foremost were
focused on how to help them in the
moment which is they shouldn't have to
pay overdraft fees and they've got loan
payments that they're worried about so
the 14 thousand customers that have
called us that's what they're focused on
that's what they need help on and that's
what we're we're gonna focus our efforts
but might you do loans we're considering
all options
Wells Fargo suffered what was called the
fake account scandal in 2017 how have
you addressed that and moved forward and
explained what happened sure what what
what happened was that we had an
incentive plan in our retail business
that encouraged our team members to sell
products over providing the right advice
and service that should not have
happened and so I stepped into this role
in the fourth quarter of 2016 and with
the full support of our board we've made
significant changes in the company I've
assembled the new leadership team from
internal and external leaders we've made
very important changes in terms of how
we pay our team members we've raised our
minimum pay to $15 an hour and then
anyone that was close to $15 an hour
we've also increased their pay that
affected 85,000 team member oh go ahead
go ahead
obviously I know you told Congress you
said you expect us to do better and we
will do better but since then we have
learned about the company wrongly
repossessing cars charging college
students excessively high bank fees what
does better look like well all of those
items that you mentioned right which
shouldn't have happened by the way where
items that we found and were part of the
promise that I made to all of our
stakeholders which is that we're going
to open every drawer look over under
every Rock I lost Fargo if we find
something we're gonna
fix it we're gonna change whatever the
process was that wasn't working we're
gonna make it right by our customers
we're going to be very transparent and
then we're going to move forward but in
addition to looking in the past we're
also looking in the future and offering
some pretty exciting new products and
services to our customers like overdraft
rewind real-time balance alert control
tower and many other products and
services that were offering for free for
our customers you've certainly taken
steps to correct the problem there but
you took quite a beating on Capitol Hill
I remember watching that thinking it was
a beating they like you were wearing
gasoline pants to meet you it was really
very fiery but some people say you were
there at the scene of the crime you've
been at the company a long time if you
didn't know about it you should have
known about it and why do you think that
you should still lead this company sure
I think it's a very fair question look
III I love this company I've I've been
at this company for 31 years in a
variety of different roles when I
stepped into this role I took
responsibility for the mistakes that we
made in the past and I pledge that we
would move forward I think I'm the right
person for this job
because of the fundamental changes that
we've made
not just in leadership not just for our
team members we've reorganized the
companies we're very focused on what
we're doing in the communities beyond
for example what we're doing for federal
workers this is a different company
today in a much better company that it
was having said that our work is not
done we still have a lot more work to
thank you for addressing all that thank
you so much